[Music]  president obama he spoke to the nation  about syria last night and there's been  a huge issue what do we do about Syria  and of course President Obama wants to  act it was to attack a lot of critics  who have complained that Obama has been  too indecisive during this entire crisis  and I personally think that indecision  showed itself again last night during  his speech and god bless the United  States of America almost exactly 15  minutes the president united states  doing is best to try to convince a very  skeptical American public that what's  happening in Syria right now is in fact  in the national security interests  did the president make the face a lot of  Americans who don't see this is a major  national security threat to the United  States that the US  that credible threat the military I mean  one of the things that was so  interesting about what  [Applause]